from the euro crisis to the refugee
influx to terrorist threats Europe is
facing many challenges and yet certain
crucial laws can take years to make with
28 member states and the European
Parliament required to ratify Commission
proposals a procedure that must speed up
for urgent issues and for the first time
the presidents of all three institutions
have signed a document that sets the
union's priorities for the following
year with the situation we have in
Europe with so many crises overlapping
what is at stake is to show that
European Union is crucial to provide
real solutions for citizens concerns the
six priorities are investment in jobs
and growth Social Security and action
for youth security migration the digital
single market and the energy union and
climate behind every vision is a
concrete project the priorities include
completing the banking union with risk
sharing to avoid a new financial crisis
and tackling tax evasion with nearly one
in five young Europeans out of work in
2015 more funds will go to fight youth
unemployment another initiative will
give European volunteers aged 18 to 30
the chance to work in areas such as
health education and refugee aid laws
promoting energy efficiency and
low-carbon investments will also be
fast-tracked
Oh